the film editor is the man who takes all  the pieces of film and puts them  together into something exciting well to  present the editing award here is a  young lady who was exciting because  she's so well put together as Miss  Esther Williams  here are the name nominated for the best  achievement in film editing Colin  Warburton for Crazy Legs Paul Bartlett  productions Republic William Lyon for  From Here to Eternity Columbia Otto  Ludwig for the moon is blue Preminger  Herbert production United Artists  Roberts wink for Roman Holiday paramount  and every Douglass for the War of the  Worlds paramount man who's the winner P  thank you the winner is William Lyon for  From Here to Eternity  thank you sincerely  I know look she doesn't own and I was  gonna be others again she drove up in a  late-model swimming pool well now I  don't know about you folks but I have to  take a break come to think of it station  has to take a break too